whenever we study projectile motion at
what i would call human scale human
scale velocities and distances we make
some assumptions that aren't exactly
true one assumption we make is that the
gravitational field is constant near the
surface of the earth and you see that
here i made that assumption when i made
this little simulation the gravitational
field is not changing the other
assumption that we assume is that the
gravitational field points straight down
so we're essentially assuming that we're
on a completely flat surface the field
is pointing straight down newton's law
of gravitation tells us that if we
actually think on a larger scale neither
of those assumptions are actually true
the farther away we get from the center
of a mass of a planet the gravitational
field will get weaker and if we get far
enough it will get significantly weaker
the other thing is if as we move around
the planet or across the planet the
planet's surface is curved and so the
gravitational field is not pointing
straight down like this it is pointing
towards the center of the planet for our
purposes here we're so we're so many
thousand miles above the the center of
the planet that it pretty much looks
like it's down but once we get to larger
scales these things don't quite hold
anymore so to think about this larger
these larger velocities in these larger
scales we've made
this little simulation it's not as cute
maybe one day we'll put some nice
graphics on it so it is but this is to
really model things a little bit more
accurately
so what you can do here is you can set a
launch angle you can set a launch speed
the launch angle is in degrees launch
speed is in meters per second and also
the launch altitude in meters and then
when you
hit the hit restart you will see the
little path of the projectile right over
there and you see it's not it's starting
to look a little bit different than the
paths that you might be familiar with in
traditional projectile motion and we can
change a lot of things the way i've
default set this is actually the size
and the mass of this object is actually
that of the moon so you can actually
think about that we are launching these
projectiles on the moon and it's in a
vacuum we are assuming that there's no
atmosphere and if you want to
if you want to make the simulation run a
little bit faster you can change this
time scale but the faster you run the
simulation the less accurate it will be
but it will get you pretty close to what
the reality is so let's say we wanted to
run it five times as fast we could put a
thousand right over here and then when
we run it you see that the entire
simulation is running faster so what i
want you to do is really tweak these
different things and think about what
what happens as the projectile gets
faster as you might change the angle so
let's say we had a low angle say a 15
degree angle let's so there you go it
kind of launches but then it hits the
planet again let's make it go a little
bit faster let's make it go 600 meters
per second
and then you see well it gets gets a
little bit fat further let's see 1700
meters per second
and we see
that it gets even further than that and
i don't know let's let's try 1850 just
to see what happens 1850 meters per
second
and then when we launch it you see that
it's getting even
it's getting even further still and you
might be wondering at some point can i
stick this thing to orbit or how can i
change the launch angle and the velocity
so i can change it put this thing into
orbit and the launch altitude so right
now it's only 10 meters but maybe i want
to make it 10 kilometers 1 2 3. so that
would be 10 kilometers i restart and
it's still hard to see because this
thing is the size of the moon
but you see here it looks a little bit
different now i can change the launch
angle once again i can actually go to a
much lower launch angle
and now when i launch it i can see all
sorts of interesting things and if you
want to change the scale of this entire
thing you go right over here to meters
per pixel so right now each pixel on my
canvas represents essentially 25
kilometers so there's a couple of things
to think about first of all do
projectiles when you really take in to
take newton's law of gravitation into
consideration do they really travel in
parabolas and if you don't think they're
traveling in parabolas what what would
describe their path the other thing
that's fun to think about is just how
based on the altitude the initial launch
angle how can you launch a projectile
into orbit how can you actually get it
to do what it's doing here and what are
the conditions where this happens and
when the when does it not and also
change the time scale because you'll see
that some of this change in the path
right over here it might be due to error
in introduced due to the simulation it's
not an absolute perfect simulation we
have to pick some time scale so as you
lower the time scale think about what's
happening to the simulation although it
will take longer to run
the other thing that you might want to
do is pick a certain altitude
set your launch angle to zero and see
what velocity you need what launch speed
you need actually to get your thing to
go into orbit and see how that actually
relates to the distance from the center
of mass and the gravitational field at
that altitude so hope you have some fun
with this let me do another actually it
would be fun actually to do a high angle
so let's do a high angle and let's do a
relatively lower velocity 1000 meters
per second which is still quite fast
about the speed of a bullet
so let's say so that's actually not that
interesting let's make it
let's make it 1500
1500 so let's
oh that's a little bit more interesting
what if we made the launch angle really
steep so you can see here this is kind
of this is kind of fun
so you can launch it at even steeper
angle just like that anyway hopefully
you have fun with the simulation and
makes you think a little bit more about
maybe the assumptions you used to make
about projectile motion